en vídeos anteriores hablamos del
concepto de transformación en particular
hablamos de transformaciones rígidas por
ejemplo podemos desplazar este triángulo
y tendremos una traslación del triángulo
original podemos tener una rotación esto
que traslade lo estoy rotando como
pueden ver y también podemos tener
reflexiones aunque la herramienta que
estoy usando no hace reflexiones muy
fácilmente esencialmente es voltearlo
con respecto a una línea pero en este
vídeo vamos a hablar de transformaciones
geométricas no rígidas lo que hace que
una transformación sea rígida es que la
longitud de cada lado no cambia pero en
las transformaciones geométricas no se
mantienen las longitudes de los lados
por ejemplo a este triángulo que rote
traslade y que sigo trasladando mientras
hablo le puedo aplicar una potencia lado
motes ya es encoger o expandir la figura
por ejemplo en este momento estoy
encogiendo el triángulo esto es una
potencia y también puedo expandirlo eso
también es una potencia en resumen no
sólo tenemos las transformas
rígidas que vimos anteriormente también
podemos tener otro tipo de
transformaciones y la homo test ya es
una transformación que veremos con
frecuencia especialmente cuando
comenzamos a ver el concepto de
transformación nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo